[Musica]
da bambina ho avrà avuto su e giù otto
anni avevo una compagna di classe A cui
invidiavo una e una sola cosa il suo
nome
nella mia testa era ricorrente un
pensiero perché mi devo chiamare per
forza Fiona e devo sempre spiegare agli
altri da dove sono di dove vengo perché
sono qui perché ho questo nome strano
perché Sì il mio nome Fiona suscitava
sempre troppe domande quando siamo
piccoli L'unica cosa che vogliamo è
appartenere vogliamo che i nostri
genitori ci vogliono bene e vogliamo
essere accettati dagli adulti da tutti
in realtà Sappiate è questione di
sopravvivenza perché un bambino da solo
non può sopravvivere quindi vuole essere
accettato Ecco io mi sono sempre
ritrovata controcorrente contro la mia
volontà sempre è faticoso sapete
questo nome così esotico io lo odiavo
perché mi faceva sentire ancora più
diversa rispetto agli altri già ero
albanese e albanese il bonus albanese in
Italia negli anni 90 era una roba
orrenda avevo due genitori che
insegnavano danza Vai a spiegare agli
altri che lavoro ai genitori che
insegnano danza e in più la mia passione
era nei videogiochi e sottolineo sono
una femmina quindi era tutto sbagliato
Ci mancava solo il nome strano e avevo
fatto bingo ero diversa punto Ma io non
volevo esserlo Questo era il mio
fardello e me lo dovevo portare dietro
Ecco perché nella mia testa di bambina
di 8 anni la soluzione era chiamarsi
Federica mi avrebbe in qualche modo
aiutato a mimetizzarmi in quel
Sottobosco di bambini oggi però ho fatto
pace con il mio nome e anche col mio
passato e anche con le mie origini
soprattutto E quando dico a tutti che mi
chiamo Fiona tutti si ricordano di me e
il mio marchio di fabbrica non potrei
più farne a meno
Scusate sono arrivata così a bomba e non
mi sono presentata Ciao a tutti sono
fino a ciacalli Ho 35 anni lo so che non
li dimostro sono nato in Albania oggi
sono un'imprenditrice una content
Creator che intasa la Timeline dei suoi
follower di video di auto e di
tecnologia tutti i giorni ho vissuto una
vita sempre
facendo il contrario di tutto ma che
cosa significa vivere una vita al
contrario per esempio il mio asilo era
un teatro dell'opera quello di Tirana
dove lavoravano i miei genitori Io non
sono mai andata all'asilo in vita mia
molti albanesi sono venuti negli anni 90
col gommone col barcone mi pigliavano in
giro sempre ma io sono venuta qui
fingendomi la figlia di un pilota di un
aereo di linea a 5 anni cioè 007 a 5
anni anche se il mio unico problema era
sapere se l'aereo andava dritto a testa
in giù Ma questa è un'altra cosa Quindi
capite bene che la mia nuova vita a 5
anni iniziava così facendo attenzione a
nascondere Chi Realmente fossi
il primo giorno di elementari ho
consumato tutte le lacrime che avevo in
corpo perché nessuno mi aveva detto che
mamma e papà non ci sarebbero stati io
non ero mai andata all'asilo quindi non
sapevo come funzionava e in tutto questo
avevo un grembiule nero e non bianco
come tutti gli altri bambini e Ma in
Albania così ce l'avevamo noi nero
grembiule Questa è mia mamma mentre gli
altri bambini avevano il supporto dei
genitori per studiare per fare i compiti
io una volta ho provato mia mamma a
chiedere Che cos'è il complemento
oggetto lei purtroppo non parlava
benissimo italiano quindi non sapeva
esattamente ho visto tipo una pagina 404
comparire qui cioè si era rotta la mamma
l'avevo mandata in tilt ho dovuto
riavviarla Poverina mi si spezzava il
cuore a vedere i miei genitori che non
parlavano bene l'italiano che spesso
prendevo i libri i miei libri di scuola
andavo lì facevo mamma adesso dobbiamo
studiare io ti dico una parola e tu mi
devi dire qual è l'articolo che legge
perché non mi puoi dire il carne è
sbagliato 8 anni cioè il mio unico
problema integrare la mia mamma Anche se
una volta però non l'ho corretta perché
ha detto la pasta oggi mangiamo la pasta
con la peste e abbiamo fatto un sacco
ridere
mi reggeva sempre il gioco quando
probabilmente il suo unico problema era
Chissà se questo mese riuscirò a mandare
dei soldi ai miei genitori a casa
trovavo le case le vite delle mie
compagne di classe di danza un paradiso
a parte la mamma di Stefania che un
giorno mi ha detto scusa ma in Albania
avete delle strade no signora noi volare
non abbiamo bisogno di strade
che fatica capito adesso perché io vado
tutte le settimane dallo psicologo
[Applauso]
tu devi dimostrare che valere più di
italiani Anzi tu meglio diceva Ludmil
che poi ludmele anche mio padre la
soluzione per spogliarmi di questa
dolorosa all'epoca albanesisità che oggi
non mi tocca neanche Anzi sono
contentissima era una sola io dovevo
dimostrare di valere quanto vuoi Anzi
forse un pochettino di più
ho iniziato quindi a competere
ferocemente con me stessa complice anche
la danza e il fatto di avere il Ludmil
come maestro c'era una sfiga incredibile
il ludwill non mi correggeva mai cioè
lui diceva Allora io non ti guardo Tu
guarda le correzioni che io faccio alle
altre ragazze e tu cerca di imparare da
sola così poi ti rafforzi ti fortifichi
Scusate Cito un
poeta contemporaneo che diceva Ma che
comportazione è questa
[Applauso]
Ecco come fin da bambina veniva
estradata intraprendere le mie passioni
come qualcosa da forgiare nel fuoco del
ferro e della disciplina da affrontare
come se fosse il più duro dei lavori ho
fatto danza anch'io per tanti anni
sapete ma il mestiere della danza non
faceva per me
Sì in realtà non ditelo a nessuno non
ero dotata fisicamente Quindi niente va
bene le passioni Va bene tutto ma
bisogna avere anche del talento e io
probabilmente dormivo quando Madre
Natura aveva deciso di distribuire il
collo del piede alle ballerine che se
non lo sapete una delle caratteristiche
fondamentali che devono avere e quindi
me ne sono fatta una ragione
nel frattempo crescevo e più crescevo
più diventavo indipendente Oh che bello
adesso sono adulta e posso decidere per
me stessa Quello che voglio fare ad
esempio uniforme Ecco non riesco Scusate
sono albanese non parlo molto bene
uniformarmi agli altri seguendo quel
desiderio di quella piccola Fiona
bambina il mio vero lavoro Il mio primo
vero lavoro a cui mi dedicai era la
commessa in un negozio di abbigliamento
ah sbagliato il negozio videogiochi
quando ero ancora bambina mio papà fece
uno sforzo economico incredibile per
comprare quello che lui chiamava
computer proprio scritto con la k perché
è la k in albanese computer scritto come
si legge lo portò dall'Italia in Albania
Diceva che tutti giocavano con questo in
Italia
e io ci giocavo era il mio gioco di
famiglia per me i videogiochi erano un
momento di aggregazione a casa l'atto
controcorrente di quest'uomo privo di
qualsiasi pregiudizio è stato quello di
regalare alla figlia femmina nel 1991
qualcosa che all'epoca ma forse anche un
po' oggi è considerata da maschi in
Albania invece non esisteva questo gioco
per cui lui non aveva nessun tipo di
pregiudizio nella sua testa per lui era
per tutti vedeva che mi divertivo quindi
per lui andava benissimo Ho lavorato Poi
per sei anni in una centrale operativa
quella di Europa Assistance una
compagnia assicurativa in euro Così la
chiamavamo ho imparato a lavorare una
grande azienda ho capito che cosa
significasse davvero far parte di un
essere un piccolo ingranaggio dentro a
una struttura gigante e ho capito qual
era la traduzione di farsi un
mazzo col mazzo così Questo è il mazzo
mazzo così
il mio lavoro era quello di salvare le
persone che si sfra rappresentavano in
giro per il mondo perché era
un'assicurazione sanitaria però seduta
su una sedia da ufficio imposti che non
conoscevo tipo trinitate Tobago Ma
chissà dov'è 'sto posto poi l'ho
scoperto dopo tre anni sentivo di aver
imparato tutto che questo tutto quello
che è questo lavoro aveva da offrirmi Ma
cosa avrei potuto fare d'altro da un
lato avevo un contratto a tempo
indeterminato e sarei stata la pupilla
di Checco Zalone e lui contentissimo del
mio posto fisso perché avevo gli
straordinari pagati
tredicesima quattordicesima ferie visite
mediche pagate ero in quel flusso che
tanto desideravo da piccola quella
normalità che agognavo dall'altra però
Arriva un fuoco talmente grande da
spingermi all'esplorazione Sì ma di cose
esattamente Beh conoscevo i videogiochi
piacevano tantissimo
Che scema dovrebbe dove avrei mai voluto
andare io quei videogiochi
ho deciso però di concedermi una
possibilità
la possibilità di iniziare qualcosa e
magari di sbagliare a casa mia con due
genitori Etoile l'errore era un po' così
Un piccolo segno una vergogna una
piccola onda Io l'ho sempre vissuto come
un modo
come modo di imparare come non fare le
cose
quindi che dire avevo 23 anni potevo
fare quello che volevo non dovevo più
rendere conto i miei genitori all'epoca
andavano di moda i blog non c'era tiktok
Non c'era Instagram c'era questi blog
bisognava farli a mano compilare un
delirio provai ad approcciare in primis
dei siti grossi di videogiochi E
ovviamente presi delle sportellate in
faccia con ovviamente pianti e grassi
risate da parte degli altri loro
ridevano io ho riso proprio poco io però
in realtà non chiedevo niente se non una
piccola possibilità di provare a
scrivere e capire che cosa volesse dire
e allora ho detto è sì volete scherzare
con Albanese Mo faccio da sola e quindi
mi rimboccai le maniche e avviai un blog
tutto mio comprai dei libri
evidenziatori inizia a studiare come si
curava un blog che cos'era il content
marketing Che cos'è un piano editoriale
Come si gestiscono all'epoca c'era
Facebook e Twitter c'erano ancora i
dinosauri Ma si usavano principalmente
queste due piattaforme
dopo giorni insonnia con grande
soddisfazione ne parlai con qualche
collega in Europa Assistance Se qualcuno
mi prese in giro dicendo Non farei mai
niente e altri invece mi aiutarono
magari qualcuno con il sito qualcuno con
la grafica era nato ufficialmente il mio
blog Games Princess Games perché
Ovviamente parlavo di quello di
videogiochi E quel Princess era un po'
così Voleva voleva dare un segno perché
quella principessa ero io e volevo
essere padrona di quello che mi sarebbe
successo del mio destino non ero lì ad
aspettare il
non ero io ad aspettare l'intervento di
un tizio baffuto in salopette che di
mestiere fa l'idraulico di chi sto
parlando io uh uh avete indovinato poi
piano piano inizia a scrivere questi
articoli che erano dei temi delle
elementari e spero non esistano più da
nessuna parte
e piano piano iniziarono a contattarmi
delle ragazze Perché volevano che
coltivavano il mio stesso sogno e la mia
stessa ambizione e mi chiedevo ma mi
chiedevano posso scrivere per il tuo
sito
No aspetta La cosa mi prendeva davvero
in contropiede perché ho detto ma cosa
vogliono queste
il mio sito è mio e poi io non sono
nessuno come mai potrei aiutarle
poi piano piano realizzai che in un modo
inaspettato forse assolutamente in modo
inavvertito il mio blocchettino perché
così lo chiamavano e così lo liquidavano
stava diventando uno spazio libero che
poteva dare il rifugio a tantissime
ragazze che volevano scrivere dei
videogiochi Ma là fuori si sentivano
giudicate
avevo inavvertitamente avviato una
piccola rivoluzione creato un porto
sicuro un esperimento di inclusività e
niente quindi iniziai ad avere queste
ragazze con me a scrivere e il mio
blogttino stava diventando qualcosa in
più inizio quindi a formarsi un team e
le ambizioni diventavano sempre più
grandi lavoravo sei ore al giorno in
Europa since turno pomeridiano e
notturno avevo tutto il resto della
giornata perché attaccavo il turno alle
5 alle 6 avevo quindi dalle 8:00 del
mattino fino alle 6 per studiare per
imparare cose nuove per imparare questo
lavoro del blogging mi distruggevo di
straordinari tutte essere stati io
prende ero quella che prendeva il
capodanno
lì tutta l'estate perché avevo bisogno
di soldi Dovevo portare a casa più soldi
possibili perché mi serviva per avviare
un'attività questa attività del famoso
blocchettino senza avere un piano senza
avere un business plan senza avere un
business Model i primi soldi che avete
che presi da Europa Assistance l'investì
per andare a una fiera internazionale E
sì avevo preso matta completamente Avevo
preso le ferie per andare a lavorare in
una fiera destinazione e tre di Los
Angeles per chi conosce il mondo dei
videogiochi le tre sa di che cosa sto
parlando è una fiera immensa gigantesca
E questa sono io con un microfono da 30
euro e una fotocamera che avevo
elemosinato agli amici di Samsung che
continuerò a ringraziare per tutta la
vita per farvi capire il mio livello di
preparazione dell'epoca non sapete
quante volte ho infilato il Jack del
microfono dentro le cuffie e facevo
questi kolossalmuti bellissimi cioè
vincevano degli Oscar
questo problema era che erano a colori
sbagliavo piangevo non mi sentivo
all'altezza e probabilmente non lo ero
all'epoca Eppure ogni piccolo errore
ogni inciampo ogni sbaglio ogni
fallimento era uno stimolo e
rappresentava la certezza che mi sta
muovendo nella direzione giusta che la
mia vita controcorrente cioè che la
stavo vivendo controcorrente per la
prima volta piccoli passi ma lo stavo
facendo perché io volevo viverla
controcorrente e quei piccoli errori mi
hanno aiutato a capire che stanno
andando nella direzione giusta
a un certo punto devo decidere cosa fare
perché non potevo lavorare 18 ore al
giorno venne quindi il momento di fare
il salto nel vuoto Dopo 6 anni l'acciaio
ero passa istance nel frattempo James
Prince sarà diventato Tech Princess e
c'era una nuova veste grafica arrivarono
anche dei collaboratori maschi nessuno
gli aveva obbligati avevano alzato la
mano mi avevano scritto dicendo a me
piace la tua realtà posso scrivere per
il tuo sito Oh zio si chiama Tech
Princess No no ma mi piace molto Ok va
bene Ero contentissima c'erano
collaboratrici nuove responsabilità
sfide E ormai il sito non parlava più di
videogiochi ma aveva iniziato a parlare
di tecnologia di auto di lifestyle e
anche di viaggi
nacque quindi una società addirittura
che gestiva tutte le attività del
portale mentre io Oltre a scrivere i
miei famosi temi che ormai erano un po'
migliorati avevo iniziato a fare video
su Video non mi sentivo all'altezza
continuava a non esserlo perché sapete
fare il video non è una cavolata cioè
fare il video è una fatica mostruosa è
un fallimento a volte feroce che
comporta fatica ed edizione in cui
bisogna metterci la faccia esporsi in
prima persona ed essere pronti a
raccogliere l'applauso del pubblico Ma
che spesso qualche uova marcia qualche
pomodoro perché capita anche quello Ma
va messo assolutamente in conto e se tu
in tutti questi anni mi sono ritrovata
appoggiare il sedere su macchine Tipo
queste una Lamborghini e una McLaren una
Tesla è solo perché Vedendo quei video
l'azienda hanno iniziato a reputarmi
all'altezza hanno cominciato a ritenermi
una professionista in grado di poter
recensire i loro prodotti le loro auto
Questo è un risultato che continua
ancora a stupirmi Ma continua a stupire
anche persone là fuori tipo il tizio che
l'ultima volta mi ha detto Oh ma la
guidi tu questa macchina Oddio Sono
appena scesa da questa macchina Come
faccio a non guidarla io questo succede
perché
oltre a essere albanese avere un nome
strano essere donna o anche passioni che
vengono reputate da maschi
questo succede di continuo Perché vivo
in un mondo cioè Anzi ho scelto di
vivere in un mondo Controcorrente ma la
cosa ha smesso assolutamente di pesarmi
la vera cosa che mi dà fastidio è che
ancora mi pesa invece è dover rispettare
le aspettative degli altri dovermi
schiacciare in un modello
preconfezionato e preconfigurato per me
dopo una vita controcorrente questa
testa Qui è dura è durissima Io voglio
romperlo con lo schema e lo faccio tutti
i giorni e ho anche dei bernoccoli da
qualche parte ma grazie al cielo non si
vedono
il mio lavoro i video le presentazioni e
le interviste i viaggi festival tutte le
cose che sono finita a fare e non avrei
mai immaginato di fare le collaborazioni
che faccio con questi colossi della
tecnologia delle auto tutto questo non
fa che riportarmi a quel passato penso a
quella bambina che si sentiva a disagio
perché aveva quel nome strano Era in un
paese diverso in un mondo al contrario
che però un giorno
decise che l'unico modo di sentirsi viva
e di sentirsi dritta era quello di
vivere controcorrente è un esercizio
inutile e anche dannoso il nostro
passato per quanto Difficile
o facile piacevole o spiacevole
ci restituisce la misura di quello che
abbiamo imparato di quello che siamo e
di quello che vogliamo essere perciò
ascoltate il vostro passato con affetto
accoglietelo abbracciatelo anche
imparate dai vostri errori errori
siate liberi pensatori e concedetevi
carezze e critiche se lo ritenete
opportuno ascoltate gli altri ma non
lasciatevi condizionare dai loro pareri
o dalle loro aspettative ma siete voi a
farlo siate liberi di scegliere la
vostra vita controcorrente che voi
abbiate un nome strano oppure no Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]